I will never forget first day you skated
up to my mother
it's significant health yes I will marry
you
it's embedded deep in the left front
lobe he could be brain damaged for life
has no insurance got it down Thank You
Arlene the nail could actually cause her
moments of wrath rage anger not a fun
wife good luck for now
did you just exchange her engagement
ring for a chicken foot well I'm from
your district I saw you want to be you
were great that idiot can't help us
what brings you to DC I came to see you
because I want to help people that have
weird conditions that they can't afford
to fix
hi Alice I guess that's all scared oh
dear that's not very manageable it was
amazing
one brief hallway conversation you've
read on all that Alice's on TV she's
amazing she has a damaged head that's
your brain you know I might still be
lovely
we know how this is gonna turn out this
woman we put it in my heart
no no
my veins I
the dance
together we can make things good again
like definitely for inspire each other
let me apologize for month insensitive
white friends and take you to Benihana
and smooth via trauma with a sake bomb